foreign
[Music]
so the new trailer for June part 2 has
just dropped and throughout this video
we're going to be breaking it all down
the teaser comes with a lot of hints at
what's going to be happening in the
movie and it also shows us elements
where they might be setting up a sequel
yep Danny Villanova stated that he wants
to do do Messiah at some point and
there's clearly some things here that
are putting things in place now I will
be trying to avoid all Major Spoilers
here but with this being based on a book
there will be some things we can't avoid
talking about so if you don't want
anything from the film potentially roon
then I highly recommend you turn off now
but we will try and keep it light
spoilers which is now the new channel
name now without the way a huge thank
you for checking this out welcome to
light spoilers I'm your host Paul now
let's get into June
please
this world is beyond cruelty
you've been fighting the Harkins for
decades
my family's been fighting them for
centuries now
they're massacred
alongside my father
my father didn't believe in Revenge
We Believe
in famine let me fight beside you
reload now we begin with the sunset of
arrakis and symbolically this shows
what's going on in the film we're about
to come to the beginning of Paul's
actual Reign and from here Darkness will
spread across the universe this is all
linked to the prophecy with the
character and in this trailer they talk
a lot about its usage and how it can
bring power now with the sun we can see
Two Moons almost eclipsing it and in
total arrakis has three moons these are
called krelin Avon and one and from here
we go to Paul and touching the sand
Laden with spices builds off the back of
the first movie when they rescued the
miners from the giant worms that was the
first time Paul actually touched the
surface with his hands and the shot kind
of has the Shimmer over it where it
looks like it's part of his dream this
is something that we saw in the first
part when he imagined chani and my guess
is that he's imagining this scene here
though we can also see Paul's eyes have
started to turn blue and this indicates
that he spent a long time with the spice
we get a hard Conan ship tearing up the
landscape and this is likely an attack
on the rebelling fremin how's our Conan
of course rules over the planet and from
here we cut her a ban and also Vladimir
adorned in Black they've now taken over
and we see their vast armies numbered in
the hundreds of thousands black banners
fly of bulking Nazi imagery and we can
also catch Vladimir floating with
metallic balls the guy was so fat that
he had to use this to get around but it
also carries this idea that he's above
all now though it seems like the
harkonians truly rule everything there's
actually a lot going on politically at
this moment Vladimir has had Rabanne
running amok on the planet and he's seen
as a bloodthirsty Tyrant that shows no
mercy Vlad is purposely allowing someone
absolutely terrible to rule over things
so that when he brings in fade things
seem a lot better fade will be played by
my man Austin Butler who's just coming
off the back of rocking it as Elvis
throughout the trailer you might notice
he's white
his wife
and any scene is the next in line to the
harconan household now we have made a
full video breaking him down if you want
to know all the ins and outs of this
specific character but I don't want to
just repeat everything from that as
we'll be here all day and I know we've
got stuff to do like hitting the Thumbs
Up Button simply put though he and the
israeli's child were supposed to get wed
and this would finally bring both of
their houses together their child will
then go on to become the quiz that's
hadarak and they'd rule over the
universe and bring everyone in line also
I double check the pronunciation I know
I keep getting crap up mispronouncing
that but I double checked it this time
another to form the quiz ax had Iraq a
lady Jessica was instructed that she had
to have a girl and spice even allows one
to choose their child's gender however
ducato wanted a son and because she
loved him she gave him one and thus this
knocked up the entire plan that they'd
had in place for Millennia the Benny
Jesuit had carefully selected Bloodlines
so that one day they could finally bring
the chosen one in for centuries they've
pushed the prophecy that this is a
Supreme Being and slowly people have
started to believe even though it's made
up what June's about is basically how
faith can be used to manipulate and make
people think someone's amazing when
really they're just terrible and also a
puppet this is something we get touched
upon later on in the trailer and Paul's
gonna have to weigh up whether he can
use this the back to fade and he's
basically pulls opposite as he's the son
of a house who's supposed to inherit
everything now the two houses not having
children that would wear this thrown
them back into an endless war which we
hear Paul talking about over the top of
the teaser he says how the fremin have
been fighting them for decades whereas
with his family he's been fighting them
for Centuries interspersed with this are
shots of the Duke's ring which we saw
the character carrying in that first
film his bloody hand can be seen here
along with all the corpses that the
Hawkins collected after the attack in
the first film cremated we then cut to a
picture of the Duke ripping on the one
of their ancestors from June part 1. we
then see the war playing out with them
summoning a dune and also blowing up an
ornithopter with a rocket launcher the
fremin skills have been built up and
improved and this is because Jessica has
shown them the weirding way
thanks
I won't be fighting for him
fighting for my people
[Music]
you young pop
do you believe in Paul
there are signs
the prophet why is that a bad thing use
it
because of all my Visions lead to horror
because you lose control because I gain
it
Johnny do you believe in me
Paula trades are still alive
now the next spot of the trailer shows
Paul being shown by some of the fremin
and I actually think this might be
connected to Jamis this is the character
that Paul killed at the end of the first
film and that was part of their ways it
hasn't gone down well in the book
killing someone like this meant you had
to also look after their family but
whether they bring this into the film
we'll have to wait and see means adding
in even more characters and I think it
might be better if they just skip it and
have Paul and Cheney on their own things
get complicated enough with the love
triangle later on but this could be used
as a way that people hate Paul as he
didn't do his duty I actually think that
this might be early on in the film as we
can see his eyes still look normal when
we go to the shot of him here Paul's
story in this film will basically be him
convincing the Prem and he's the chosen
one and then they'll start to fall in
line and become extremely loyal so it
makes sense that they would start off
being like sod the guy don't like his
video don't subscribe and then he's got
to win the round with his Charming wit
and humor now had he not weaponized the
prophecy then he wouldn't be able to get
them round and he becomes very
manipulative in order to seize power now
June has lots of comments on religion
like this and how it can be used as a
way to help control the masses the idea
that you might go to hell if you're bad
is kept people in line over the
centuries and religions of course have
their figureheads that people get behind
Paul is this one and if people believe
they're following the Messiah they're
more likely to do horrendous things
because it's quote unquote God's way we
see Chaney conflicted by this and she
says she's not fighting for him but yeah
she too seems to get swept up in this
false prophecy now the movie also asks
the question if prophecies can be forced
to come true if people believe in them
hard enough and want them to be real
they start to see the signs popping up
everywhere and we can see is still go
get swept up in believing Paul's the one
riding on a worm we watch his face in
absolute ore and also hear Jessica
asking if he believes in Paul he says
there are signs and starts to convince
himself too which makes him fall in line
and then start to worship him not on the
other side of this we have my man
Kearney halek who survived the attack
from the very first film coming face to
face with Paul in the desert the Peril
United and is forces alongside the
framing helped to make an army now you
might notice that his hair's a lot
longer than it was in that first movie
and this shows how long that they've
been out in the desert the latter part
of the book spans several years and this
is how Paul gains the blue eyes that we
see him rocking now it turns out that
Gurney had ended up joining with some
Smugglers and over time he'd become the
leader of them stelgar was attempting to
take this unit out but when Paul saw
Gurney both sides stepped down United
they became a much larger force and this
gave Paul great numbers to go up against
the harkonens we even see Gurney
suggesting Paul used the prophecy for
power and he'll of course need to get
everyone to fall in line now his
response is that all of his Visions led
to horror and unfortunately that comes
true when we get into the sequel people
start carrying out horrendous acts on
those that don't obey and he leads a
holy war against the rest of the
universe his followers are extremely
devout and will fight to the death we
which the other armies and houses simply
on a matchful according to the buck the
Jihadi carries out kills 60 billion in
his name and the Visions he's having are
coming as a warning now Gurney says that
Paul might be worried that he loses
control but Paul says it's more because
he gains it this of course comes to be
with him gaining power and this causes a
lot of Destruction in the Galaxy
alongside this we see the Water of Life
being touched as part of the ritual that
will allow lady Jessica to become a
reverend mother we also get the blade
charm from the final fight with fade and
this is between the two sons for who
will take control of arrakis we see the
blade stain so I'm guessing Paul managed
to get a hit but there's a big curveball
that then gets thrown in we see erlan
and the emperor learning Paul's alive
and the man Christopher Walkens now
walking on thin ice why in case you
don't know era Lance's daughter and
she's possibly gonna inherit a War
caused by her father the emperor scheme
with the hawkonen to take out the
Atreides because as a house they were
just getting too popular so hot right
now and this is why they gave their
Maracas in the first place as it would
be the planet that was gonna bring them
down however we see that this hasn't
been the case and now the emperor is
worried that he's gonna lose it all he
ends up doing something with his
daughter that I don't want to spoil here
but we will talk about it at the end of
the video if you want to know that
deal with this prophet
[Music]
was a weak man
look who's back from the dead
how do I must be done
we gave them something to hope for
as long as I breathe
this prophecy is how they enslave us
it's not a prophecy it's a story I don't
care what you believe I believe
thank you
I am Paul boy Diva treaties
joke Uncle Ruckus
[Music]
he who can destroy a thing has the real
control of it
[Music]
foreign
and he talks about how they have to deal
with Paul over this we see a thumper
calling in a worm and the fremant of
course have found a way to weaponize
these creatures and the way the emperor
wants to bring Paul down is through the
use of fade who we see in the next shot
in high contrast black and white talked
about this in the other breakdowns but I
believe this is a flashback with the
color scheme being used to highlight
it's in the past the first movie didn't
feature him at all even though in the
story he's a pretty big pot so I think
they're kind of retroactively
introducing him here to show what he was
up to while Sierra trades had just taken
the planet a skilled Warrior this plays
into the end in which both he and Paul
have a knife fight to the death now this
is something that's shown towards the
end of the trailer and I believe we see
other elements for it when we catch the
emperor he says that the Duke was a weak
man and we also see his ring along with
the painting that burns amongst the fire
this was shown in the first teaser and
it does look more like the pain that I
talked about before and I'm guess
someone grabbed the ring off the finger
that we saw and then pass it on to Paul
come the end of the trailer we see him
putting this on and then announcing
himself as the Duke of arrakis now his
dad was somewhat of a pacifist that
didn't want a war and this is why the
emperor is here calling him weak he's
taunting Paul to not following his
footsteps and from here we get shots of
the battle playing out on the planet he
was a zero ban going up against Gurney
and this is a vendetta the pair of
carried since that first film Paul
questions whether Chaney actually
believes and we do sort of get the idea
that she she kind of sees through all
the BS she's of course very close to the
entire thing and knows Paul as a person
so I'm guessing that they might either
use it or be like look how it can
corrupt people or just showing the
falseitude of it altitude as that word
now in the end prophecies have of course
been used to control the people and had
this not been put in place and I doubt
people would have got behind Paul
starting to sound like a broken record
going over this entire thing but yeah
that's kind of the themes that I'm
getting from this teaser now probably my
favorite shot on the trailer comes when
we get a bird's eye view of what we
initially think our grains of sand
however this is revealed to actually be
the fremin Army and we see Paul moving
amongst the middle of them sand of
course contains spice and spices what
everyone's fighting for and it also
exemplifies how the plenum people have
become his army Jessica says Paul gave
the people hope but we know that what he
really did was throw them into war now
we see this playing out along with the
cost of it which has Channing now almost
taking the place of what was shown in
his vision I don't think it's any
coincidence that this looks some of that
scene from the first film where he
imagined himself on the battlefield
partaking in the war however he sees how
it's become channy and it shows how his
Visions can be slightly off now the
first film had him getting ones where he
thought he would die fighting Jamis
however we know that that didn't come to
be true however the character did die in
many respects and it shows the Visions
can be interpreted differently Paul
shouts out to her but I'm guessing this
is stitched together from another scene
because I don't know if he'd just be
standing off to the side during such a
big battle now we actually see the setup
to this coming later on when we watch
the two sides charging at each other
either way he promises he'll love her as
long as he breeds but yeah we'll get
into that towards the end of the video
now it's clear that Paul just doesn't
believe the prophecy but even still
God's now so ingrained into it that he
just won't see the truth it shows how
Faith Can often override it and even
when stuff's shown to be false if you
believe it you won't falter Paul's going
to be enforced down this path and we
then see his army as well as the worms
that he's now controlling it leads to
some gigantic set pieces and some
incredible explosions with Paul hoping
that because he can destroy his fate
that he can control it he will get
forced into doing things and it will
consume him though and he'll create a
monster that he simply can't control now
that's how he sells things with the
emperor I wanted to leave this until the
end in case he's someone who just
doesn't want to know that part of the
film if you don't then huge thank you
for singing until now and we're now
going into the trademarked heavy
spoilers territory dude staying with me
you better you son of a now Paul
ends up beating fade and this kind of
leaves the emperor completely
knowing he's next he instead tries to
form an alliance and he offers up his
daughter to take Paul's hand in marriage
Paul agrees because it'll avert more
Bloodshed but it causes a big issue
between him and channy man married to
stop a war but his personal feelings
have unfortunately now been pushed to
the side anyway that's how it all plays
out and I have to say yeah it's this
trailer it blew me away looks absolutely
incredible and it just seems like
they're stepping everything up and
really delving into the subtext the film
looks breathtaking and I can't wait to
see it and hopefully this video has
helped you appreciate what's happening
anyway let us know your thoughts in the
comment section below and if you want to
support the channel for as little as 99
cents a month then please click the join
button and as a thank you you'll get
early access to videos every week we
also have our merch store over at shop
zeroedition.com which solves lots of
nerdy inspired t-shirts hats and more
we've just launched a secret Invasion
slash Pulp Fiction shirt so if you if
you're enjoying the show to help us out
then head over to the link in the
description now if you want something
else to watch we've got a video on
screen right now going over everything
that happens in the latest episode
hopefully I see you over there but if
not you know what thanks for watching
until this point I'll see you on the
next one you take care yourself by the
way I've been poor you've been the best
and I'll see you next time much love for
peace